cynthia nixon
oh my god
oh my god you look so sexy thank you i
mean meow
wow
real the last time we were together we
were um
really just taking an unprecedented tour
through marishka harcate's house amazing
house which she came on and i was able
to finally be transparent about going
through her entire home every level the
attic to the basement it's the most
special house i've ever it's like really
in one of my top 10 houses of all time
it's a magic house it is a magic house
and i got to be with you and your wife
and we just talked and we had the best
time and i love the fact that we've both
been doing this our whole lives and
we're still here and just like that
we're still here
okay
i
grew up with this show i love this show
you guys created one of the most
important
institutions
the facet of every woman um at different
ages
we've all changed roles
we've we speak to one character at one
point they're all the facets of a woman
wrapped up in one divided into four yeah
is it true that it was almost a
difficult choice for you something you
battled with grappled with to do and
just like that well yes if you revisit
something that was such a big part of
your life and so iconic i mean it's a
big step but also
it seemed to me we're very different
people now we're very different ages now
we were we were in our early 30s when we
started we're 55 56 now um and the world
is very different and it was you know i
wanted to be sure and i think we all
wanted to be sure that
when we went back we we could save a lot
of what was great about the original and
fix what was maybe not so great like the
fact that it was such an overwhelmingly
white show
that we would really open open up the
door and invite these new characters in
and really do right by them so that we
could get great actors and actresses to
play them and nicole and karen and
sarita just came on the show i know i
know um okay sarah ramirez
i am freaking out
um
is it true that you
hand-picked them i suggested them
because i've been aware of them for so
long
and such a fan and you know
um
mike nicholls i worked with mike nichols
a bunch of times particularly when i was
young and he cast sada in spamalot for
which they won a tony
so i always felt this you know i was
always watching their career and stuff i
love che so much i feel like i know
quite a few
um personalities
that are very truth-saying
uh very
sharp-pointed
funny matter-of-fact kind of calming
forces do you feel like you know
a che
do i feel like i know a che i mean yes i
do the person who is who often will you
know become a performer of some kind
because
every room they're in they're kind of
the superstar in their room because of
their charisma and their wisdom and
their wit which is so appealing and so
sexy also when you are saying i dm'd you
and you didn't get back to me
and sada's like
i get a lot of dm calm down
try again this happens or
the family blowing up i'm not doing this
you fix your side of the street right i
mean i think it's we've seen in the past
when miranda gets you know is attracted
to someone that intimidates her and she
tries to get all aloof and miranda
doesn't know what she wants from this
person or what she's allowed to want but
also the important thing to remember is
like chase a celebrity right they just
had their first netflix special so add
that on top of everything else on top of
the fact that they're non-binary on top
of the fact that miranda's married on
top of the fact that you know she hasn't
had sex with anybody but her husband in
a very long time okay
[Music]
you